peut-être que c'est plutôt effectivement
sur les intitulés qu'on va mettre
l'accent plus effectivement que sur la
date
deux fois par mois depuis le mois
d'octobre anne charlotte et sandrine se
rendent compte rentrer marraine et
filleul anne charlotte est demandeuse
d'emploi mère de quatre enfants elle
cherche à reprendre son parcours
professionnel
c'est plus un projet professionnel en
fait que je viens chercher parce que je
suis un peu perdue devant l'étendue et
puis peut-être pas très sûr de moi étant
donné que j'ai pas trahi pendant
quelques années j'ai une formation
juridique donc ça pourrait être le
juridique mais voilà je suis ouverte à
beaucoup de choses aussi
sandrine et salariés des yvelines comme
11 autres membres de la structure elle
s'est portée volontaire pour participer
à une job academy
une première pour l'établissement
départemental suis assez intéressé par
l'accompagnement les questions liées à
l'emploi m'intéresse et puis j'ai j'ai
la curiosité de l'autre et je trouve
qu'on se nourrit aussi beaucoup de
l'expérience de l'autre et ils sont
vraiment ils surent faire un de
l'ensemble de nos directions nous avons
des travailleurs sociaux des personnes
de la rh des systèmes d'information nous
avons même des personnes de la direction
générale des services donc voir un large
panel de nos métiers
la job academy ce sont aussi des
ateliers en groupe 4 mois des changes
professionnelle initiée par face
yvelines la fondation agir contre
l'exclusion
comment on arrive chacun d'entre nous à
surmonter une épreuve parce que il ya
toujours un moment dans la vie où manque
de confiance en soi partage de moments
difficiles ou d'espoirs lors de la
recherche d'un emploi un moyen de
trouver des clés techniques et morales
est ce qu'on appelle nous aller vers une
meilleure employabilité
c'est ce qu'il va donner cette impulsion
par un accompagnement qui est
personnalisé paix qui est surtout fait
dans le cadre de l'entreprise atelier
des changes mais aussi ateliers
pratiques ce matin la simulation
d'entretien est faite par un membre des
ressources humaines et une marraine
anne-charlotte postule à une offre
d'emploi de juristes des droits des
affaires on a l'impression passer un
vrai entretient donc c'est bien c'est un
bon ça booste et ça aide à se préparer
ça motive et puis elles m'ont donné
aussi plein de petits trucs elles m'ont
dit aussi ce qui n'allait pas et sur
lequel il fallait travailler un peu donc
non c
et très constructif dans quelques jours
anne charlotte retrouvera sa marraine
pour finaliser son projet professionnel
la job academy se termine le 31 janvier
sur les douze filles elles accompagnent
et six ont déjà trouvé un emploi